Kolleginnen und
Kollegen politische Verantwortung gibt
man nicht am Kleiderhaken ab dazu steht
man Herr Mütze nicht das waren ihre
Worte gerade genau das hätten wir heute
an diesem Rednerpult erwartet es gab
kein Wort das bedauern es gab keine
Entschuldigung dieser ampelregierung
meine Damen und
Herren Bundeskanzler haben heute dem
Deutschen Bundestag und der
Öffentlichkeit mitgeteilt dass die
Anwendungsregeln der Schuldenbremse vor
diesem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil nicht wirklich
bekannt gewesen wären sie haben weiter
der Öffentlichkeit und im Bundestag
mitgeteilt dass das Verfassungsgericht
über eine
Staatspraxis geurteilt hätte und sie
haben ferner Herr mützenig auch noch die
Dreistigkeit besessen davon zu reden
dass die Schul enbremse vielleicht sogar
diesen Betrug provoziert hätte ich will
ihnen sagen wie die Realität an dieser
Stelle ist diese Worte diese Worte von
ihnen Staatspraxis nicht bekannt wie die
Schuldenbremse wirkt und dann auch noch
zu behaupten dass es vielleicht die
Grundlage für den Betrug ist das zeigt
die ganze Arroganz und Respektlosigkeit
wie sie mit diesem Urteil
umgehen
es war ihre ampelregierung Herr
Bundeskanzler die Sie zu verantworten
haben die sich Milliarden
vorratsschulden in den Keller gelegt hat
die sich nach Belieben über Zeitpunkt
und Zweck der Ausgaben dieser
schuldengelder selber entscheiden wollte
und die alle Welt glauben machen wollte
dass sie die Schuldenbremse einhalten
obwohl jetzt klar ist mit dem
nachtagshaushalt dass sie 45 Milliarden
über die Schuldenbremse ausgegeben haben
und deswegen hat die Süddeutsche
natürlich recht wenn sie am Wochenende
titelt die Tricker das ist das Prädikat
ihrer Ampel und ich sage es sind nicht
nur Tricker sondern es ist schlichtweg
der Betrug an der Schuldenbremse der
hier begangen worden
ist und jetzt haben wir heute wieder
gehört D wie ein Mantra das ständig vor
sich hergetragen wird dass es ja auch in
der Vorgängerregierung schon einen V mit
überjährigkeit gegeben hat der in den
Haushalt eingestellt worden ist was sie
dabei was sie dabei aber verschweigen
ist erstens dass dieser vond hatte nicht
ihre buchungstricks um die
Schuldenbremse zu übergehen und zweitens
dass der
Bundesfinanzminister zu diesem Zeitpunkt
Olaf Scholz geheißen hat und deswegen
hat das Verfassung icht nicht über eine
Staatspraxis entschieden sondern das hat
über das System Olaf Scholz entschieden
und es auuser Kraft
gesetzt sie haben dabei übrigens alle
Warnungen außer Acht gelassen alle
Warnungen die auch jetzt in den letzten
Tagen ja wiederholt worden sind der
persönliche Berater des Finanzministers
Professor Lars Feld hat es noch mal
deutlich gesagt wörtlich zitiert trotz
der Bedenken im
Bundesfinanzministerium vor und nach dem
amtsbeginn der Bundesregierung kam es zu
dieser Entscheidung der Stabilitätsrat
hat sie explizit damals darauf
hingewiesen wörtlich zitiert damit droht
dass das verfassungsrechtliche Ziel der
Schuldenbremse faktisch ausgehült wird
Warnungen gab es genug sie wollten sie
ignorieren sie wollten sie schichtweg
ignorieren und auch das sagt das Urteil
es ist schlichtweg die Arroganz die sie
am Schluss dazu gebracht hat dass sie
die Verfassung gebrochen haben meine
Damen und
Herren und her Bundeskanzler sie haben
heute mit keinem Wort erwähnt wie unsere
europäischen Nachbarn über diese
Finanzkrise in Deutschland denken die
Menschen allerdings haben einen sehr
klaren Eindruck davon bekommen was sich
in unserem Land verändert hat dass beim
Besuch der italienischen
Ministerpräsidentin hier in Berlin bei
ihrem gemeinsamen Auftritt die
italienische Ministerpräsidentin von
Journalisten gefragt wird im Bezug auf
ihre Finanzfragen ob da Deutschland noch
ein verlässlicher Partner ist das hätten
sich die Menschen in unserem Land
niemals vorstellen können das berührt
die Menschen und das man meine dam zeigt
die ganze Verzweiflung in der Sie diese
Bundesregierung gebracht
haben in Europa werden aktuell die
Verhandlungen über einen gemeinsamen
Haushalt geführt der stabilitäts- und
Wachstumspakt der wird auch neu
verhandelt werden die Akzeptanz über das
Einhalten von Regeln spielt dabei eine
ganz entscheidende Rolle und wir haben
das in der Vergangenheit schon mal
erlebt denken sie zurück an die
eurofinanzkrise was wir da erlebt haben
die
Finanzstabilität und Solidität
Deutschlands die hat die gemeinsame
Währung zusammengehalten Deutschland war
es die den Euro am Schluss gerettet
haben wenn die Haushaltsregeln in
Deutschland nicht mehr eingehalten
werden dann wird es schwer in Europa
unsere Partner zur
Haushaltsdisziplin zu bewegen das heißt
der der Bundeskanzler mit ihrer Politik
gefährden sie die Finanzstabilität in
Europa das ist die
Wahrheit ich hätte heute übrigens
erwartet dass sie ein klares Bekenntnis
abgeben Herr Bundeskanzler dass sie die
Schuldenbremse 2024 einhalten wollen ich
hätte dieses klare Bekenntnis erwartet
weil es ein paar andere verstörende
Wortmeldungen der hier gegeben hat Herr
Mützenich ich habe sehr genau aufgepasst
sie haben mehrfach die Ukraine in ihrer
Rede erwähnt sie haben mehrfach von
unnormalen Zeiten gesprochen das ist
doch nichts anderes als dass sie
vorbereiten wollen dass
2024 die Schuldenbremse auch nicht mehr
eingehalten wird und ich will ihn damit
auf die Reise geben bei ihren Beratungen
wir werden auf absehbar Zeit keine
normalen Zeiten mehr erleben wer das als
Ausrede nimmt der wird nie wieder zu
soliden Haushalten zurückführen meine
Damen
derr und anstatt dass sie dem Bundestag
und der Öffentlichkeit mitteilen wie sie
die Schuldenbremse
2024 einhalten können sind weite Teile
ihrer Koalition jeden Tag damit
beschäftigt darüber zu diskutieren wie
man die Schuldenbremse abschaffen kann
oder wie man die Schuldenbremse
aufweichen kann das ist schlichtweg kein
Bekenntnis zum Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse und der Regeln wir haben
am Parteitag wir haben am Parteitag der
Grünen Herrn habbeeg auch sehr genau
zugehört der formuliert hat mit der
Schuldenbremse ein Zitat mit der
Schuldenbremse haben wir uns freiwillig
die Hände auf den Rücken gefesselt und
ziehen in einen Boxkampf nur mal hier zu
den Fakten in diesem Jahr
2023 ist es möglich mit Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse legal über 40 Milliarden
Euro neue Schulden zu machen im nächsten
Jahr ist es legal beim Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse möglich über 20
Milliarden neue Schulden zu machen sie
wollen einfach nicht mit diesem Geld
zurechtkommen für sie reicht dieses Geld
schlichtweg einfach nicht aus und
deswegen sage ich Ihnen Herr habbeck die
Ampel ist doch kein Boxer dem man die
Hände gefesselt hat die Ampel ist ein
schuldensüchtiger dem bei der
Beschaffungskriminalität entdeckt und
erwischt
hat wissen Sie die Schuldenbremse wurde
doch genau deswegen eingeführt um so
eine Politik zu verhindern die
Schuldenbremse wurde doch genau deswegen
eingeführt um vorzubeugen dass Politik
ausschließlich auf Kosten der kommenden
Generation gemacht worden ist die Schuld
gemacht wird die Schuldenbremse soll
doch schlichtweg verhindern dass die
Ausgaben ins Uferlose wachsen sie soll
disziplinieren das ist doch schlichtweg
die Aufgabe der Schuldenbremse und
deswegen sage ich Ihnen auch an dieser
Stelle sie können mit uns
selbstverständlich darüber reden wie man
solide Haushalte aufstellt aber wir
reichen keine Hand dafür unsolides
Haushalten in dieser Bundesregierung zum
Dauerbeschäftigung zu machen wir geben
ihnen nicht die Hand dafür dass die
abschaffen der Schuldenbremse
legalisiert wird dafür haben sie nicht
unsere
Unterstützung so wir waren jetzt auch
überrascht zu hören dass Sie Herr müz
den Haushalt
2024 noch in diesem Jahr beraten wollen
es hat gestern ein Schreiben des Bundes
Finanzministers der hat in diesem
Schreiben an alle Kolleginnen und
Kollegen darauf hingewiesen dass er den
Haushalt 24 gemeinsam mit dem Haushalt
25 beraten will das riecht nicht danach
dass das in diesem Jahr noch stattfinden
kann möglicherweise sind auch sie hier
nicht einig und möglicherweise sind sie
auch hier nicht in der Lage eine
gemeinsame Linie zu finden ich kann ihn
an der Stelle nur sagen das was der
Bundesfinanzminister in der letzten
Debatte hier formuliert hat Bildung
Sicherheit
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wörtliches Zitat
all das ist möglich bei den bestehenden
Einnahmen ohne Flucht in neue Schulden
oder höhere Steuern Herr
Bundesfinanzminister wir nehmen sie
schlichtweg hier beim Wort dieses Land
hat kein Einnahmeproblem es hat
schichtweg ein ausgabeproblem das heißt
setzen sie
endlich setzen Sie den Sparstift an
dieses Land braucht schlichtweg kein
heizungsgesetz das dem Staat und Bürger
Milliarden kostet es braucht keine 5000
neuen sacharbeiterstellen um die
Kindergrundsicherung auszubezahlen und
es braucht kein Bürgergeld dass die
Menschen die sozialhilel treibt und
nicht in die Arbeit integriert braucht
dieses Land
nicht und sehr geter
Bundeskanzler dass sie das Wort des
Bedauerns und der Entschuldigung hier
nicht in der Lage waren gegenüber der
Öffentlichkeit und dem Bundestag zum
Ausdruck zu bringen das empfinde ich
schlichtweg als nicht angemessen ich
empfinde das nicht als angemessen und
ich kann ihn sagen dieses Land braucht
und keineasen zeigen sie Führung und
beenden sie endlich dieses ampeldrama
herzlichen
Dank Alexander dobrin der vor und hinten
in seiner Reg Rede darauf hinwies dass
diese Bundesregierung sich nicht
entschuldigt haben für das Finanzielle
disaster was jetzt droht es se ein
Betrug an der Schuldenbremse wir geben
ihn nicht die Hand dafür dass die
Abschaffung die Abschaffung des der
Schuldenbremse in diesem Land
durchgeführt wird das werden wir nicht
mitstimmen jetzt also Chan Kindler von
den Bündnisgrünen Schuss W Führung keine
Phrase hat ihre Rede sehr gut
ausgezeichnet und
zusammengefasst und ich hätte mir auch
ein bisschen mehr Demut gewünscht wenn
ich ih Rede gehört habe angesichts der
Maut die Sie beschlossen haben aber das
ist vielleicht Stilfrage die von ih
untercheidet
Herz wollte was zu ihr rede sagen sie
haben sich als Mann der 90er Jahre gehen
sie nach hinten aber ich wollte trotzdem
no noch mal
eingehen ich find ja gut dass sie dazu
stehen dass sie ein Mann 90er Jahre sind
ich find gut wenn man selbst steht woll
darauf hinweisen hat auch der FDP
Kollege schon hingwiesen Herr ich bin
sehr froh dass der heutige
Wirtschaftsminister Robert habbe heiß
nicht Jürgen Möllemann um das klar zu
sagen har für die FDP aber ich glaube da
gibt ein breiten Kons inem
Haus und in den 90er Jahren Herr März
waren sie schon im Bundestag ich war
Grund aber ich habe damals schon
aufgepasst wie die finanzpolitischen
Rahmendaten waren und ich will sie noch
mal erinnern wie das war weig war
Finanzminister die Staatsschulden in
Deutschland 600 Milliarden 600
Milliarden Deutsche Mark DMark auf 1,45
Milliarden DMark gestiegen 850
Milliarden demar die statschonen von
1990 bis 1998 gestiegen es gab eine
Vermögenssteuer noch in Deutschland in
den 90er Jahren dieige sogar erhöht es
gab ein soliditätsbeitrag der
spitzensteuersag lag lag % und die
Schuldenbremse war nicht im Grundgesetz
ich finde spannend dass S diesen
finanzpolitischen rahendaten orientieren
wollen dass das Vorbild nehmen ich bin
gespannt ob wir intiativen dazu in der
nächsten Zeit her
märz und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das bundesverfassungsricht hat uns einen
klaren Auftrag gegeben und ich will hier
sehr klar sagen das war ein Fehler der
zweite Nachtragshaushalt 21 darum kann
man nicht drum rum ren und gleichzeitig
hat es aber massive Auswirkung für die
Staatshaushalte in Bund und Ländern
aktuell hat gerade reiner Haselhoff per
Deutsche Presseagentur erklärt dass ihr
Sondervermögen dass S in Corona
aufgenommen haben mit notlagenkrediten
dafür 2023 und 2024 die Notlage erklären
werden genauso macht es Daniel Günther
CDU Ministerpräsident in
schlesäig-holstein der Landtag hat es
beschlossen 2023 2024 die Notlage
erklärt das heißt wir haben noch eine
gemeinsame Verantwortung jetzt auf
Grundlage dieses Urteils darf man sich
nicht wegducken muss man der
Verantwortung auch stehen als
Union
und ich glaube das unterscheidet eben
Friedrich März und die
Oppositionsfraktion der Union hier im
Deutschen Bundestag von den
Regierungspolitikern die im
Verantwortung stehen die CDU
Ministerpräsidenten und andere Politiker
in Verantwortung stehen müssen sich im
konkrete Gedanken machen wie wir
zukünftig Haushalte aufstellen das
machen Kai Wegner das machen reiner
Haselhoff das macht Michael kretschm das
macht Hendrik wüst die ja alle darüber
gesprochen haben dass sie ein
Modernisierungsbedarf bei der
Schuldenbremse sehen weil sie sich die
Frage stellen wie können wir zuk e noch
Investitionen finanzieren oder nach
diesem
Urteil und es ist stellt sich eben die
Frage wie können wir jetzt es hilft der
nächsten Generation noch nichts wenn
durch Schulen durch die Decke tropft es
hilft der nächsten Generation nichts
wenn die Infrastruktur verrottet wenn
Eisenbahnbrücken gesperrt werden müssen
nicht mehr fahren werden können es hilft
der nächsten Generation nichts wenn die
klimaneutrale Transformation der
Wirtschaft jetzt gestoppt wird und
deswegen müssen wir darüber reden wie
wir diese Investition in Zukunft
finanzieren können und Wirtschaft
wirtschaftspch ist auch sinnvoll sich
ein Unternehmen zu investieren jedes
große jedes kleine jedes mittelständ
Unternehmen finanziert Investitionen
nicht nur aus Eigenkapital nicht nur aus
laufenden Einnahmen sie finden
Fremdkapital anders gesagt über Kredite
über Schulden weil es eben nachhaltige
Investitionen geht werthaltige
Investitionen geht die neues Vermögen
schaffen deswegen machen das Unternehmen
wir müssen darüber reden wie wir im
Rahmen der Schuldenbremse die wir nicht
abschaffen wollen aber die wir erweitern
wollen die wir öffnen wollen für
Investition jetzt wieder Investition
schaffen wir freuen uns auf Vorschläge
aus der CDU wir freuen uns auf
Vorschläge CDU Ministerpräsident
und ich will jetzt klar sagen es geht
beim den 60 Milliarden jetzt im KTF geht
es um Klimaschutz es geht um die
Einhaltung von Gesetzen es geht die
Einhaltung von Abkommen das
völkerrechliche Pariser Klimaabkommen es
geht um das Klimaschutzgesetz und es geh
Kern der Generationengerechtigkeit dass
unsere Kinder unsere Enkel noch eine
Zukunft wie Planeten haben darum geht es
beim
[Applaus]
klimatransformationsfond ze ich auch
darum bei den 60 Milliarden Euro um die
Zukunft der deutschen Wirtschaft es geht
darum wie wir grün Stahl schaffen können
wie wir die Chemieindustrie umbauen
können wie wir die Zementindustrie
umbauen können es geht darum dass
solarproduktion es geht um die
windkraftproduktion nicht nur in USA und
China stattfindet sondern dass sie in
Deutschland stattfindet es geht darum
dass batteriezellenproduktion in
Deutschland in schlißlich hutstein
stattfindet es geht darum dass wir die
Gebäudesanierung organisieren und
finanzieren es geht um die mobilitäts
Ende und zwar überall in Deutschland in
Sachsen in SachsenAnhalt in Brandenburg
in schlesig-holchland im Saarland in
Bremen nerw überall es geht um 10000
100.000 Arbeitsplätze die wir nicht
gefährden dürfen und deswegen haben wir
eine gemeinsame Verantwortung das jetzt
langfristig zu finanzieren diese
gemeinsame Verantwortung haben wir alle
die Bundesregierung die Koalition hier
im Parlament die demokratische
Opposition und die Landesregierung diese
gemeins Verantwortung müssen wir jetzt
annehmen
danke
als nächster hat das Wort für die AFD
Fraktion Peter
böringer frau Präsidentin wir erleben
historische Wochen die Rechtsbrüche und
Fehlentscheidungen von Jahren
kulminieren in einer Haushaltskrise
hinter der sich eine Regierungs und auch
eine vernunftkrise verbirgt die
Schlussfolgerung des Kanzlers aus einem
zwingenden Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts sind abwegig und
unlogisch die Regierung kann nicht
rückwirkend für 2023 die Fortdauer einer
unkontrollierbaren Notsituation
behaupten nachdem sie selbst diese 2022
für beendet erklärt hatte es geht
nicht man durfte gespannt sein ob
diesmal über eine energienotlage
begründet werden würde oder über Kriege
im Ausland oder über erneut
aufflammendes coronabüten oder über die
unmittelbar B vorstehende erdüberhitzung
wir haben es ja eben gehört von hern
Kindler oder vielleicht eine Sturmflut
wie sie vorige Woche in
schlisswig-holstein als
notstandsbegründung bereits für 2024
herhalten musste gestern Abend kam dann
nun die Auflösung der Krieg von Februar
22 und sogar die Arai Flut von 2021
sinden an der Not
2023 all das entdeckt Sie direkt nach
dem Urteil und ganz plötzlich im
November 23 rückwirkend für Januar auf
welch peinlichem Niveau sollen wir hier
noch getäuscht
werden diese Begründung diese Begründung
dem Bundestag zur Abstimmung zuzumuten
wird gleich der nächste Verfassungsbruch
sein weder 2023 noch 2024 besteht eine
Notsituation im Sinne des Artikel 115
Grundgesetz man halilt keinen
Verfassungsbruch durch einen weiteren
Herr Kanzler auch das demonstrative
entfernen an dieser Satz hilft ändert
daran überhaupt
nichts sie haben und Sie hören es ja
noch als Kanzler in einer ihrer ersten
Amtshandlungen zusammen mit dem neuen
Finanzminister Lindner den absurden
nachtragshausalt 21 dann im Januar 22
beschlossen und darin auch schon die
eindeutig verfassungswidrige
buchungssystematik die illegalen Kredite
der Sondervermögen über viele Milliarden
Euro sollten die Spardose sein zur
Umsetzung der gesellschaftsändernden
rotgrün gelben Ziele die gesamte Politik
die algemeinpolitik der CO2 hysterischen
energievorgaben der Masseneinwanderung
der woken
gesellschaftstransformation der
industriefeindlichkeit der Milliarden
teuren Corona lockdowns und der
waffengeschenke ins Ausland wären ohne
diese Gelder nicht denkbar
gewesen leider leider hat in das
Verfassung Gericht ist jetzt die
finanzielle Geschäftsgrundlage entzogen
dutzende Milliarden zu spät Deutschland
wird nun schon seit vier Jahren seit
vier Jahren finanziell notregiert es
weht ein Hauch von Weimar dort wurde ab
1930 notregiert meist gestützt auf
Notverordnungen seit 2020 werden von der
groko und auch von der Ampel durchgängig
nun Notsituationen erklärt die
Schuldenbremse wird so geschrtert das
Grundgesetz Anhalt gen das müssen die
Menschen
wissen die Grünen Chefin Ricarda lang
fordert sogar schon die dauerhafte
Aussetzung der verfassungsrechtlichen
Schuldenbremse Herr müzenig hat eben
auch mehr als angedeutet man fordert
einen permanenten Notstand wir werden
auch für die nächsten Jahre die
Aussetzung diskutieren müssen das ist
die Debatte die ansteht sagt Frau lang
die Ampel steht vor dem politischen
moralischen und finanziellen Bankrott
assungskonform kann das Land nur noch
mit einem grundlegenden Kurswechsel
regiert werden die selbsternannte
demokratische Mitte die ach
demokratische Mitte hat mit mindestens
drei Haushalten an der Verfassung
vorbeiegiert und der SPD Fraktionschef
hat ja eben an dieser Stelle vor wenigen
Minuten das Grundgesetz als Monstranz
bezeichnet als peinliche als peinliches
Relikt schä sie sich her nicht wo ist
der Verfassungsschutz wenn man ihn
bräuchte wo ist er das sind Anschläge
gegen die F
hier an diesem Pult man kann sich nicht
dauerhaft aus einer Krise drucken man
kann die Jahrzehnte alten Lebenslügen
der Politik alle Altparteien nicht
dauerhaft mit Schulden und Steuergeld
kompensieren ich habe das hier an dieser
Stelle im Bundestag schon bei der
Ausrufung der ersten Notsituation im
März 2020 genauso gesagt es geht immer
noch nicht Herr Scholz ihre von Anfang
an ungedeckten vorsätzlich illegal
ausgestellten Schecks haben die deutsche
misereie sogar verschlimmert wäre dieses
Geld nicht ausgegeben worden dann Stände
Deutschland heute nicht nur finanziell
sondern umfassend besser da weil dann
auch eine Menge gesellschaftspolitischer
Blödsinn nicht finanzierbar gewesen
wäre und sie alle haben seit kolschen
scheckbuchzeiten mitgemacht die AFD ist
bereit diesen Schut wegzuräumen aber
erst dann wenn sie die fähig
Entscheidungen einräumen und den Weg für
einen Neuanfang frei Maen für eine
endlich wieder rational national
geführte Regierung dann besteht trotz
der horrentenschäden durch seit 8 Jahren
aufgegebene Grenzen und durch Billionen
an zinstragender Verschuldung die noch
Haushalte bis 2070 belasten werden die
Chance auf Rettung Deutschlands mein
letzter Satz doch zunächst braucht es
ihren Abgang als läuternde katarsis der
in der klassischen Tragödie die
Voraussetzung für Heilung ist vielen
Dank
peter böringer war das für die AFD der
hausitspitische Sprecher meiner Seite
einen schönen guten Tag und ein
herzliches Dankeschön für den für die
netten Glückwünsche heute Morgen und wir
führen
inonw hat jetzt das Präsidium übernommen
Frau berel hat schon gratuliert wird
heute 44 Jahre jung herzlichen
Glückwunsch auch von dieser
Stelle
p das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hat
wegweisenden Charakter wir spüren das
erleben wir seit dem 15 November die
Auswirkung kurzfristig und wir werden
längerfristig damit arbeiten müssen wir
werden in dieser Woche den
Nachtragshaushalt 2023 beschließen oder
einbringen um Rechtssicherheit
herzustellen es wird ein technischer
Nachtrag sein ohne zusätzliche Schulden
mein Kollege bereits darauf hingewiesen
wir werden sogar mit 27 Milliarden Euro
die
Nettokreditaufnahme deutlich reduzieren
können und ich möchte das an dieser
Stelle auch wenn wir am Freitag darüber
diskutieren werden noch mal klar sagen
die 115er Notlage bezieht sich auf die
Situation Anfang des Jahres
2023 und wenn wir gewusst hätten wie das
Bundesverfassungsgericht
urteilt und die Schuldenbremse auslegt
den hätten wir die Notlage für 2023
Anfang des Jahres
gezogen der
Bundeskanzler hat zurecht darauf
hingewiesen dass der Haushalt
2024 nach dem Prinzip Gründlichkeit vor
Schnelligkeit zu beraten ist und der hat
von einer neuen Realität gesprochen die
neue Realität ist die Härtung der
Schuldenbremse die Schuldenbremse steht
und ich andere Redner haben ja auch ihre
Perspektive hier geschildert ich sehe
keine Notlage in
die am Ende die Kriterien des
Grundgesetzes erfüllen und das ist der
auslegungsmaßstab an den sich alle
halten müssen Konsolidierungsdruck
rechtfertigt kein Aussetzen der
Schuldenbremse wir dürfen nach dem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil nicht in ein
weiter so verfallen und wir dürfen auch
nicht auch vor respektor aufgrund des
Respekts vor dem Verfassungsgericht
sofort in ein Diskussion um die Reform
der Schuldenbremse fallen auch da müssen
wir uns doch ehrlich machen auch da
müssen wir uns doch ehrlich machen wir
haben das ganze letzte Jahr und dieses
Jahr verschiedene Vorschläge bekommen
warum man gegebenenfalls eine Notlage
zusätzlich erklären könne und wir haben
in Wahrheit auch die Debatte seit 2022
darüber dass man die Schuldenbremse
gegebenenfalls reformieren möge oder
solle mit der FDP sehe ich hier wenig
Gemeinsamkeiten wir werden dies nicht
zulassen in dieser
Regierung wir haben kein
Einnahmeproblem wir sagen wir müssen
priorisieren und wir müssen
konsolidieren und das wäre auf diese
Koalition in Wahrheit auch bei den
Haushaltsberatung 2025 zugekommen wir
werden es jetzt machen müssen dies wird
härter werden wir müssen Ausgaben
beschränken der Kanzler hat es gesagt
und Schwerpunkte setzen
und ich möchte hier ebenfalls noch mal
auf die Situation in den Bundes Ländern
zu sprechen kommen das eine ist ja die
Frage wie unionsgeführte Länder oder
Länder wo die Union beteiligt ist sich
zu der Schuldenbremse und diesem
urteilverhalten und wie die
buchungspraxis in diesen Ländern
war und es ist glaube ich auch nicht
erstaunlich dass die Wirtschaftsminister
Anfang dieser Woche begrüßen und
bestätigen dass der Bund weiter mehr
Geld geben soll das ist ja das Prinzip
was die Bundesländer in den letzten
Jahrzehnten perfektioniert haben wenn
wir hier darüber reden dass 50
Milliarden Euro der Bund jetzt schon
übernimmt für die Länder ist das z.B
auch ein Thema was wir uns
perspektivisch angucken aber ich möchte
hier die CDU beim Wort nehmen Herr März
sprach am Anfang von nicht bekannter
Dreistigkeit ich frage sie was machen
sie in den Ländern wo neue
Sondervermögen eingerichtet werden die
eklatant gegen das Urteil aus karlsruh
verstoßen z.B hier in Berlin was machen
sie
da her da ist aber Herr andere reden ja
noch von der CDU können sich ja dazu mal
Verhalten Sprachen hier von einer
staatsbürgerlichen Verantwortung die
Verfassung einhalten zu müssen oder
dafür zu sorgen dass die Verfassung
einhält heißt das dass sie eine konkrete
normkontrolle gegen das Land Berlin
anstrengen werden als Union das wäre
konsequent wenn man ihnen glauben könnte
dass sie hier Verteidiger deremse sind
ich komme zum Schluss die Antwort können
Sie vielleicht geben vor uns liegen
Wochen der Wahrheit das ist gut so am
Ende des Tages werden wir das Land
stärker aufstellen wenn wir den Haushalt
2024 aufgestellt haben ich danke
ihnen Christoph Meer hat hier die
Wahrheit am Schluss ausgesprochen wenn
dieser Haushalt 2024 aufgestellt wird
darüber werden die fraktionäre noch ein
wenig streiten wie das geschehen soll
nächster Redner Achim Post erste
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
für die SPD sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren
wenn man diese Debatte verfolgt hat und
das haben wir alle gemacht die einen
mehr die anderen weniger ich mehr komme
ich zu dem Schluss dass ich mir
gewünscht hätte dass es nach dem Urteil
von karlsruh das genauso ist wie die
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Grünen der SPD
und der FDP beschrieben haben ein Urteil
das wir sehr ernst nehmen als Ampel und
als koalitionsfraktion ich hätte mir
wünscht etwas gerade auf Seiten der
Unionsfraktion etwas weniger
Schadenfreude etwas weniger
Häme etwas weniger Triumphgefühl oder
Gefühle und dafür etwas mehr am besten
sogar deutlich mehr Bereitschaft zur
Verantwortung zur wirklichen
Zusammenarbeit denn das ist das was wir
angesichts der Lage in der wir nun
wirklich sind die man nicht ausdenkt ja
nun wirklich sind bei Kriegen in der
Ukraine bei einem brutalen Krieg in der
Ukraine wo kein Ende abzusehen ist bei
einer Lage im Nahen Osten die nach dem
menschenverachtenden Angriff von Hamas
auf Israel außerkontrolle geraten könnte
nicht muss und in einer Lage liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wo es darum
geht wo wir in globaler Konkurrenz bei
einer sich zuspitzenden Klimakrise
unsere Wirtschaft umbauen wollen
ökologisch umbauen wollen dann ist es ja
wohl dringend von Nöten auch mal darüber
zu reden wie man genug Geld für
Investition für Zukunftsinvestition
mobilisieren
kann und mein fraktionvorsitzender Rolf
Mützel ich hat darauf hingewiesen dass
es um mehr geht als das was der eine
oder andere hier gerade angesprochen hat
es geht auch um die Frage ob in Zeiten
wie diesen
der soziale Zusammenhalt in diesem Land
der enorm unter Druck geraten ist
dadurch besser würde indem man an eine
sozialstad rangeht und kürzen will bei
Krankenhäusern Pflege und Gesundheit
liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das müssen sie gleich sagen
müssen sie gleich sagen zum WSF und zum
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond und zum
Klima und transformationsfond das sind
ja keine Dinge die man sich aus Lust und
Tollerei ausgedacht hat sondern wir
haben ja wohl die Notwendigkeit für die
Trans Formation unserer Wirtschaft und
wir haben ja wohl die Notwendigkeit was
für Klimaschutz zu tun und es ist gut es
ist sogar sehr gut dass wir den
Wirtschafts- und stabilisierungsfond
geschaffen haben und mit Finanzmitteln
ausgestattet haben denn damit haben wir
energiepreisbremsen organisiert die
Millionen von Menschen geholfen haben
die unseren Betrieben geholfen haben um
sicher sicherer durch diese Krise zu
kommen und das ist durch diese Politik
des Bundeskanzlers und der Ampel
gelungen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und wenn wir über
den Haushalt 23 reden ist es ja wohl das
Mindeste was man erwarten kann dass am
besten alle demokratischen Fraktionen in
diesem Hause zustimmen denn wir reden
darüber dass wir ansonsten wenn wir
diesen Haushalt jetzt so nicht machen
würden die Bürgerinnen und Bürger ja
wohl bitten müssen das was sie bekommen
haben an energiepreisbremsen
zurückzuzahlen und wir müssen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in nordest fahen
und in rheinlandpalz im ahal in
badmünster Eifel in Hagen darum bitten
doch die Hilfen die wir angefangen haben
zurückzuholen und die müssen wir weiter
bezahlen und die wollen wir weiter
bezahlen deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es war richtig den WSF zu
schaffen und es ist richtig dass wir das
so machen wie diese Bundesregierung ist
jetzt
vorschlägt und
dann kommen wir doch mal zu dem was an
Kritik geäußert
wurde was ich rausgehört habe was an
Kritik geäußert wurde in der
Bereinigungssitzung war das nicht
möglich weil die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der CDU CSU zwar körperlich
anwesend waren aber sich an der Debatte
nicht beteiligt haben sie haben 14
Stunden geschwiegen 14 Stunden keine
eigenen Vorschläge gemacht und ich hatte
mir erhofft dass diese Vorschläge heute
kommen vielleicht kommen sie ja jetzt
wenn man Kritik übt sollte man das
reflektiert machen in der Zeit nicht nur
der großen Koalition in der
Regierungszeit von Angela Merkel hat es
14 Sondervermögen gegeben
14 angefangen von der Kinderbetreuung
über die digitale Infrastruktur hin zu
der fluthilfe alles sinnvolle Maßnahmen
sagen Sie das doch mal dass das
vernünftig war liebe Kollegin und
Kollegen von der CDU CSU machen Sie das
doch
mal und wenn wir über den Haushalt 24
reden natürlich müssen wir darüber reden
wie wir das was wir uns vorgenommen
haben wie das was dringend geboten ist
finanziert wird und ich verstehe
überhaupt nicht wo man von vorne rein
meint man müsse eines der möglichen
Instrumente vom Tisch nehmen natürlich
muss man darüber nachdenken ob es
sinnvoll ist die Schuldenbremse auch in
24 auszusetzen denn sonst denn sonst
müssen wir darüber nachdenken dazu
kürzen bei Dingen die ich gerade
angesprochen habe dann sagen Sie uns das
doch wo sie das wollen wollen sie kürzen
beim Sozialstaat wollen sie kürzen bei
der Rente wollen sie kürzen bei der
Pflege machen Sie doch mal Vorschläge
ich habe von ihnen in den letzten 10
Tagen seit dem Urteil in Karlsruhe
nichts aber auch rein gar nichts
gehört und wenn wir schon mal dabei sind
ganz zum Schluss dieser Debatte wo sich
die Demokraten darüber streiten was der
richtige Weg ist kann ich nach dem
unfleätigen Verhalten ist noch das
netteste Wort was mir einfällt gerade zu
Beginn dieser Debatte von Seiten ganz
rechts außen nur eins sagen es ist
richtig und bleibt richtig sie sind
keine Alternative für Deutschland sie
sind eine Schande für die bundespolik
und deshalb zusammengefasst diese Ampel
unter der Führung des Bundeskanzlers
unter der Führung des finanzministerster
der Führung des Wirtschaftsministers
haben ordentliche Vorschläge gemacht
meine Fraktion wir das unterstützen
schönen
Dank der Bundeskanzler hat heute morgen
seine Regierungserklärung abgehalten und
der Bundestag debattiert nach wie vor
darüber nächster Redner hier Matias
für diete frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen ich muss mich
leider dem Urteil anschließen dass die
Rede des Bundeskanzlers heute maximal
enttäuschend war und zwar nicht nur mit
dem Blick nach hinten was die
Verursachung dieser Misere
angeht Stichwort keinerlei Demut aber
vor allen Dingen auch keinerlei
Eingeständnis der
Mogelei um die Schuldenbremse herum an
der sie ja selbst kanzler adpam
maßgeblich beteiligt waren aber noch
schlimmer will ich Ihnen gleich erklären
Herr Meer noch schlimmer ist dass der
Blick in die Zukunft wie wir die Lage
jetzt bereinigen ja noch trostloser ist
weil sie nichts konkretes sagen konnten
zum Haushalt für das nächste Jahr zum
Haushalt 2024 und wir haben hier jetzt
in der Debatte völlig unterschiedliche
Standpunkte dazu gehört die einen wollen
noch mal die notlagenklausel bedienen
die anderen wollen den Haushalt jetzt
noch mal grundlegend umstellen also die
Bürger und das ist das entscheidende
dieses Land befindet sich in einer
ernsthaften Lage die Bürger sind maximal
verunsichert aber den entscheidenden
Beitrag dazu liefern sie selbst ihre
eigene Regierung dieser permanente
ampelstreit sie sind und das hat der
Kollege Bartscher genau richtig
angesprochen jetzt kann man ja mit so
einem Urteil und einem anderen Urteil
rechnen aber sie haben sich ja noch
nicht mal auf den Fall dieses Urteils
vorbereitet von dem Plan B von dem
irgendwie die Rede war haben wir nichts
bisher erlebt Null sie haben keinen Plan
B für das nächste Jahr hat diese
Regierung kein haushalterisches Konzept
das ist die Bilanz dieser Debatte und
das ist ein katastrophenzeugnis für Sie
Herr Bundeskanzler um es ganz klar zu
sagen her ich s ihnen sie haben
kritisiert das hätte ja mal ein bisschen
zeitiger und dies und das sein sie mal
froh sein sie mal froh dass das
Verfassungsgericht noch in diesem Jahr
entschieden hat jetzt haben sie noch die
Chance einen Nachtragshaushalt zu machen
und die Lage zu reparieren hätte das
Verfassungsgericht im Januar entschieden
dann hätten sie die komplette Lücke von
45 Milliarden im Nachhinein auffüllen
müssen das wäre der komplette Bankrott
für ihre Politik gewesen lieber Herr
Kollege melberauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage vom Kollegen autrit
gerne sehr gehrter Herr
Mittelberg der Regierende Bürgermeister
von Berlin Kai Wegner fordert eine
Reform der Schuldenbremse und hat hier
gerade einen Maulkorb durch den
parteichf Friedrich März erteilt
bekommen die ostministerpräsidenten
wollen ebenfalls eine Reform der
Schuldenbremse in Schleswig-Holstein
wird die Notlage auch
2024 noch mal ausgerufen und in
SachsenAnhalt haben wir eben auch
erfahren auch dort wird
2023224 die Notlage ausgerufen auch ein
CDU Ministerpräsident Herr haselhof wie
erklären sie eigentlich dieses Chaos in
der CDU und wir erklären Sie dass Sie
keinerlei Vorschlag hier bringen können
tatsächlich mal systematisch diese
Fragen zu
lösene
kollegeelen ihre Zwischenfrage ich kann
kein Chaos in der CDU zu diesem Punkt
erkennen nein es geht da jeweils es geht
da jeweils um die entsprechenden
Klauseln in den länderverfassungen und
die sind auch höchst unterschiedlich
ausgestaltet wir reden hier über die
Schuldenbremse wir reden hier über die
Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz für ja in
der Folge da haben sie recht Herr
Fricker aber wir haben für den Bund und
wir reden ja hier heute über ihren
Haushalt und ihre
Haushaltspolitik darüber reden wir sie
haben z.B ich will es ihnen gerne
erklären im kommenden Jahr einen
verschuldungsspielraum innerhalb der
Schuldenbremse von allein ca 22
Milliarden sie hatten auch für dieses
Jahr einen großen Spielraum und den
haben sie komplett ausgeschöpft also sie
haben auch innerhalb einer
Schuldenbremse durchaus Flexibilität
aber ich will ihn gerne generelle
Bemerkung auch als Antwort mit auf den
Weg geben das Schuldenmachen der
Vergangenheit führt jetzt dazu dass wir
in unserem Bundes Haushalt 40 Milliarden
jedes Jahr aufwenden nur für Zinszahlung
hätten wir in der Vergangenheit nicht so
viele Schulden gemacht und dann nehme
ich uns auch selber in die Verantwortung
hätten wir nicht so viele Schulden
gemacht dann hätten wir mit der jetzigen
Lage überhaupt gar kein Problem weil wir
jedes Jahr 40 Milliarden mehr zur
Verfügung hätten um die Probleme zu
lösen und die 60 Milliarden die ihnen
fehlen aus dem Nachtragshaushalt die
ziehen sich ja über mehrere Jahre das
heißt diese Lücken könnten sie locker
auf
so und ich will ihn noch einen weiteren
Punkt
nennen sie haben hier noch mal Herr D
wiederstrapaziert es beträfe auch
Vorgänger Regierung diese buchungspraxis
ich habe ihnen mal mitgebracht die Seite
160 aus ihrem eigenen Koalitionsvertrag
und den können Sie mal nachlesen da
haben sie diese buchungsregel nämlich
bewusst geändert im letzten Satz steht
da zu lesen entsprechend wird die
Befüllung eines Sondervermögens als
Abfluss aus dem Kernhaushalt den
verschuldenspielraum reduzieren sie
haben ersetzt die Regel dass der das
gezählt wird zu dem Zeitpunkt wenn der
Bund einen Kredit begibt haben sie
geändert ganz bewusst durch eine interne
Umbuchung vom Kernhaushalt in das
Sondervermögen das hat ihnen diesen
faulen WSF ermöglicht und wenn Sie diese
Regelung in ihrem eigenen
Koalitionsvertrag Herr D hören Sie mal
sorgfältig zu nicht beschlossen hätten
aber dann h sie keinen verfassswigen WSF
das heiß wir müssten gar keinen
Nachtragshaushalt für dieses Jahr machen
wir bräuchten keinen
Nachtragshaushalt das ist der Punkt und
spannend und das möchte ich Ihnen
abschließend mit auf den Weg geben
spannend wird noch zu klären sein wer
die eigentlich ursächlichen
Verantwortlichen für diese Umgehung der
Schuldenbremse waren denn mit der
Entlassung von Herrn Gatzer da haben sie
völlig Recht der Mütz nicht ist es nicht
getan aber die Blicke wenden sich dann
nicht an auf Herrn Lindner der
wenigstens mal so mutig war die
politische Verantwortung zu übernehmen
sondern die wenden sich an den Herrn
Bundeskanzler denn der ist der
Auftraggeber dieser Aktion herzlichen
Dank Matthias midelberg von der Union
hat hier noch mal dargestellt dass es
durchaus Unterschiede gibt beim
Schuldenmachen nächster Redner jetzt
Sebastian Schäfer für die
bisk sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen es ist das
Selbstverständliche Recht der Opposition
vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht zu
ziehen das ist essentiell in unserem
Rechtsstaat die Union hat mit ihrer
Klage Recht bekommen und wir müssen
konstatieren dass dieses Urteil
tiefgreifende Auswirkungen auf die
finanziellen Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten
von Bund und Ländern hat wer
Verantwortung trägt und das tun wir auf
den verschiedenen Ebenen in der
Demokratischen Mitte dieses Hauses der
muss in schwierigen Zeiten Lösungen
finden z.B endlich umweltschädliche
Subventionen abbauen da steht ja auch in
unserem Koalitionsvertrag und da gibt's
Potenzial die ökonomische Situation in
unserem Land war schon vor dem Urteil
schwierig unsere Wirtschaft stagniert
ein drastischer Einbruch konnte in
diesem Jahr verhindert werden unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger unsere
Unternehmen haben sehr rational agiert
gerade im vergangenen Winter wir haben
das als Koalition mit den richtigen
Mitteln unterstützt mit preisbremsen mit
Unterstützung für die Industrie das war
finanzverfassungsrechtlich falsch
aufgesetzt deshalb korrigieren wir das
jetzt aber kommen wir mal zum soliden
Haushalten der Union wir haben bei der
einzelplanberatung keine Anträge der
Union gesehen Teil lag zwar vorher dem
Spiegel vor die wurden dann aber
kurzfristig wieder zurückgezogen deshalb
beziehe ich mich auf einen plenarantrag
den sie hier vor wenigen Wochen
eingebracht haben sie wollen den
Verteidigungshaushalt um 10 Milliarden
Euro erhöhen darüber kann man reden aber
da muss man auch über eine
Gegenfinanzierung reden was haben sie da
vorgelegt zu Lasten des gesamthaus also
10 Milliarden die da irgendwie im
Bundeshaushalt rumschwirren sie wissen
nicht wo weil sie genau wissen dass das
nicht so einfach ist deshalb legen sie
endlich Konzepte
vor gerade jetzt werden infolge der
Pandemie und der geostrategischen
Verschiebungen auf der Welt viele
Produktionsketten neu aufgest gestellt
auch deshalb ist diese Zeit jetzt so
entscheidend für unsere Volkswirtschaft
und wirtschaftliche Verbindung zu China
ist stark damit entsteht ein weiteres
Risiko wir sehen doch wie sich China im
globalen Wettbewerb aufstellt da geht es
sehr gezielt um die Märkte auf denen die
Unternehmen aus Deutschland in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten so erfolgreich
waren es geht da um den Kern unseres
Wohlstandes nicht nur bei uns in
Baden-Württemberg im ganzen
Land unsere Unternehmen unsere Industrie
die wirtschaftsministerinnen und
Minister aus Bund und und Ländern aber
auch die ökonominen und Ökonomen in
unserem Land sind sich einig wir müssen
gerade jetzt die Zukunftsfähigkeit
unserer Volkswirtschaft unterstützen
sonst brechen uns Kompetenzen weg sonst
drohen fadenrisse es liegen die ersten
makroökonomischen Studien vor die die
Folgen eines möglichen Ausfalls
staatlicher Unterstützung für die
Transformation aufzeigen wir können es
uns doch nicht leisten dass unser
Wachstum im nächsten Jahr um fast 1%
sinkt wie das projiziert wird das
betrifftus neue Arbeitsplätze die nicht
geschaffen werden das hat negative
Konsequenzen auch für die
Lohnsteigerungen das hemt private
Investitionstätigkeit und die
unternehmerischen Aktivitäten im Land
das behindert Innovation all das was wir
jetzt so dringend brauchen wir dürfen im
globalen Wettbewerb nicht weiter an
Boden verlieren rolf mützenig hat das
ausgeführt wir werden die
Herausforderungen
dem ung der Energiewende der
geopolitischen Herausforderungen nicht
ohne einen grundlegenden Umbau der
Infrastruktur eine Modernisierung des
Kapitalstocks schaffen es geht jetzt um
die Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Landes das
ist unsere gemeinsame Verantwortung
herzlichen
Dank und der nächste Redner meine Damen
und Herren ist einer der fraktionslosen
Abgeordneten Verena Hubert oh nein da
war ich verrutscht zunächst kommt Verena
Hubert von der SPD sie ist
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der
Sozialdemokraten
nicht aber ich bin auch
da sie stehen auf meiner Liste als
nächste Rednerin und als übernächste
Redner kommt erst her
fle genau gut dass es auch noch mal den
ein oder anderen Zettel gibt für die SPD
Fraktion hat jetzt das Wort veren
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir müssen uns
doch in dieser Debatte mal bewusst
machen wo wir eigentlich gerade stehen
nämlich an einem Scheidepunkt es geht
darum wie wir unser Land gut aufstellen
für die Zukunft und wie wir die
Transformation auch schaffen und dabei
und das muss man sich mal klar machen
kann man auch nicht nur gewinnen sondern
es gibt auch jede Menge zu verlieren und
deswegen ist das was wir hier Vorhaben
auch keine sondern eine Pflicht und
Verantwortung die wir alle miteinander
tragen hier auch gute Lösungen zu
finden und natürlich ist diese
Transformation auch eine
Jahrhundertaufgabe und nicht etwas dass
wir einfach mal so tun sondern wir
müssen doch dafür sorgen dass
zukünftiges Wirtschaftswachstum hier
auch möglich ist Arbeitsplätze entstehen
Arbeitsplätze auch gehalten werden
können unser Fraktionsvorsitzender rolf
mützenig hat eben noch mal klar gemacht
wir müssen nicht nur über den Atlantik
gucken was die USA machen mit dem
Inflation reduction Act da reicht auch
der Blick nach Großbritannien wo
Milliarden mobilisiert werden um
Zukunftsindustrien anzusiedeln und das
wollen und das müssen wir auch im Sinne
einer aktiven Wirtschaftspolitik hier in
Deutschland tun Batterien Halbleiter
Wasserstoff das ist doch der Motor der
dieses Land hier zukünftig auch am
Laufen hält und deswegen darf er nicht
in Stottern
kommen
und Liebe Union liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der CDU CSU wir haben
wahrgenommen sie wünschen sich die 90er
Jahre zurück das heißt aber auch ganz
konkret
Massenarbeitslosigkeit Jahre der
Rekordverschuldung und nicht zuletzt
einen kompletten Reformstau bei dem wir
teilweise heute noch beschäftigt sind
das ganze mal wieder zu beheben
Stichwort klasfaser und deswegen muss
man Herr März ja fast danken dass er
heute mal kurz die Maske ab gesetzt hat
und seine ja doch etwas rückwärtsgeandte
Weltsicht hier präsentiert hat früher
war alles besser und am liebsten noch
mal zurück dahin danke
schön wir haben andere Ideen für die
Zukunft unseres Landes und wir wollen
uns jetzt auch alle ernsthaft
miteinander die Frage stellen wie
kriegen wir das gemeinsam hin und die
Situation ist ernst die Situation
erfordert unser aller Verantwortung mir
macht Mut wenn ich die Ampel sehe dass
wir immer gut und gerne miteinander
diskutieren dass wir auch natürlich an
anderen Blick haben auf die Dinge aber
dass wir es am Ende des Tages auch
miteinander hinbekommen die großen
Fragen unserer Zeit auch zu lösen und
das werden wir auch diesmal wieder
miteinander
schaffen und natürlich akzeptieren wir
das Gerichtsurteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts und natürlich
müssen jetzt alle Vorschläge auf den
Tisch wie wir diese großen benötigten
Milliarden Investitionen auch stemmen es
ist aber auch unsere Aufgabe als Politik
nicht immer nur Schubladen aufzumachen
und Konzepte rauszupacken die wir alle
schon kennen sondern man darf ja auch
mal über den Tellerrand hinausschauen
wir als SPD Bundestagsfraktion haben in
Dresden letztes Jahr Papiere beschlossen
macht man gerne macht man oft aber ich
finde da gibt's auch noch einen
Vorschlag drin der UN ganz konkret
vielleicht ein Teil dieser Antwort auch
mitliefern kann und zwar haben wir uns z
einen staatsfond ausgesprochen der auch
tatsächlich ein Fond ist wo wir privates
Kapital auch in diesem Land mithebeln
für die Innovationskraft dieses Landes
und die zukünftige Infrastruktur die es
doch jetzt genau zu modernisieren gilt
und da lade ich Sie alle gerne ein auch
mal Konzepte mit auf den Tisch zu
bringen und nicht nur Häme nicht nur
Freude über das wo wir hier alle gerade
miteinander auf unseres Landes zu lösen
haben verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lassen sie mich zum Schluss kommen der
Bundeskanzler hat eben noch mal
dargelegt in welchen multiplen Krisen
und Kriegen wir uns befinden und da ist
die Welt nicht so wie wir sie uns in
aller Gemütlichkeit der 90er Jahre
vielleicht manchmal zurückwünschen und
deswegen sage ich ärmelhoch krempeln
Kraftanstrengung Lösungen finden dafür
sind wir gewählt und das werden wir auch
miteinander hinkriegen
virena Huberts war das für die SPD die
stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende und jetzt einer der
vielen fraktionslosen Abgeordneten hier
ich habe es vorhin schon mal angekündigt
der auch sehr häufig sich zu Wort meldet
das ist Robert
fahale sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ein
klares Urteil gesprochen die Umwidmung
der Corona Kreditermächtigungen zur
Umgehung der Schuldenbremse war ein
vorsätzlicher
Verfassungsbruch die Umsetzung des
gesamten Koalitionsvertrages der Ampel
beruht dementsprechend auf Täuschung und
betrug der jetzt aufgeflogen ist es
sollten Steuergelder in Milliardenhöhe
veruntreut werden und für die große
grüne Transformation verschwendet werden
die im Ergebnis darauf abzielt die
soziale Marktwirtschaft in eine
ökosozialistische Planwirtschaft
umzubauen das Geschäftsmodell der Ampel
besteht im Kern darin unsere
Energiebasis und kernindustrien
mutwillig zu zerstören und die negativen
Folgen dieser Fehlentscheidungen mit
Schulden finanzierten
subventionsprogrammen zu vertuschen um
den großen Aufschrei in der Bevölkerung
zu vermeiden und den Traum vom CO2
freien Wolken kuckuckshalim weiter
träumen zu können heizungswände Atom und
Kohleausstieg der Verzicht auf das
russische Erdgas die Sackgasse mit der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft die sich in
nächsten Jahren so erweisen wird weil
das geht nämlich gar nicht wie sie das
wollen das Märchen vom grünen stahlplatz
sowieso schon die Zerstörung der
Automobilindustrie durch das
verbrennerverbot sind allesamt keine
Investitionen in die Zukunft sondern
katastrophale Fehlentscheidung und
unsere Wirtschaft wird schneller vor die
Wand gefahren die Insolvenzwelle rollt
die große grüne Transformation ist
nichts weiter als ein
deindustrialisierungs und
umverteilungsprogramm von unten nach
oben Konzerne kassieren die
fördergeldmilliarden von Herrn habbeck
während die Bürger auf den
Staatsschulden jahrzehntelang hängen
bleiben diee über ihre Steuern
Jahrzehnte lang abzahlen
müssen frage ich mich was bleibt jetzt
von dieser Debatte
übrig die Ampel trickst mit unserer
Verfassung sie bricht unsere Verfassung
sie ist das Bündnis von verfassungsfein
aus dem Bundestag das ist die Erkenntnis
die man aus dieser Debatte rausziehen
muss ihre Redezeit ist vorbei ich komme
zum Schluss es hilft nur eins
strafsanktionen gibt es noch nicht die
fordere ich aber hiermit dass auch
Politiker für solches Handeln bestraft
werden können und in Haftung genommen
werden können in Zukunft und der letzte
Satz das ist der letzte wirklich meine
Damen und Herren der Wähler soll
entscheiden nur noch Leute ins Parlament
zu wählen die verantwortlich handeln und
ihre Wort
halten vielen Dank dass Sie diesen
Antrag hier eingebracht haben das
Verfassungsgericht hat gut entschieden
vielen
Dank leider ist es bei Robert F immer so
dass er seine Redezeit grundsätzlich
etwas
überzieht das kennen wir hier im
Parlament schon prsidentin her bei ihnen
ist noch nicht mal ein Shakespeare Zitat
richtig da kann ich nur noch den Titel
sagen wie immer viel Lärm um nichts bei
Ihnen meine Damen und Herren ich habe am
Anfang die etwas schwierige Aufgabe
meinem Fraktionsvorsitzenden
widersprechen zu müssen er hat gesagt
Markus Söder hätte bisher noch nichts
zur Schuldenbremse gesagt sei ja erst
Dienstag ich muss ih leider korrigieren
letztes Jahr hat Markus Söder der
Kollege dobrin wei das hat das aber in
seiner zeminütigen Rede bewusst
verschwiegen ganz bewusst vor einem Jahr
gesagt er stelle die Schuldenbremse in
Frage er zweifle am Sinn der
Schuldenbremse wörtlich Hilfe für Land
und Leute geht vor Prinzipien Reiterei
und das ist das was diese Koalition mit
dem Haushalt 23 macht weil ihnen Land
und Leute wichtiger ist als ihre
juristische
Prinzipienreiterei her und dann sagt ja
die CDU CSU leider ist der
Fraktionsvorsitzende jetzt schon weg sie
hätte doch ganz genau gewusst das klar
war dass hier eine Verfassungswidrigkeit
bezüglich der 60 Milliarden dass das
nichtig ist dass man das nicht hätte
machen dürfen und Papier ist ja geduldig
es gibt eine Drucksache 204579
Entschließungsantrag der CDU CSU
Fraktion unter der Führung Führung
geht's ja anscheinend rum von Friedrich
März da steht dann das Vorgehen beim
zweiten shaushalt mit der Umwidmung der
coronakredite in klimakredite und der
Transfer in Höhe von 60 Milliarden Euro
ist rückabzuwickeln und Achtung und
jetzt kommt der verräterische Satz und
damit die Neuverschuldung zu senken sie
wollten diese 60 Milliarden nicht
streichen sie wollten sie nutzen für
ihre Programme was sie danach in ihrem
Antrag gemacht haben und wer dann
dahingeht und sagt das ist ja alles
überhaupt nicht überraschend gewesen
obwohl er selber das für nichtig
erklärte Geld genutzt hat der sollte
hier in diesem Plenum mal ganz andere
Worte verwenden meine Damen und Herren
es geht doch im Kern es geht doch im
Kern meine Damen und Herren um etwas
ganz anderes hier es geht um die Frage
dass wir alle merken dass die Frage wie
dieses Land in den letzten Jahrzehnten
bei ihnen in den 90ern bei ihnen in den
30ern die Linken sind schon fast ganz
weg dass dieses Land vor Herausforderung
steht und egal wer an der Regierung ist
wir werden uns verändern müssen es gibt
dieses wunderbare Zitat von joseppe
Tomasi die Lampedusa wenn wir wollen
dass alles so bleibt wie es ist dann ist
es nötig dass sich alles ändert und das
ist das was wir klar machen müssen was
diese Koalition auch will weil sie weiß
das wichtig ist dass etwas bleibt dass
dieses Land ausmacht ein
marktwirtschaftlicher ein sozialer ein
verantwortungsvoller ein nachhaltiger
Staat das ist das Ziel dieser Koalition
und ich habe immer noch die Hoffnung
dass das auch noch das Ziel der CDU CSU
in den nächsten zwei Jahren hier sein
wird und schließlich geht es dabei doch
um etwas ganz Wichtiges geht do um das
Versprechen der Bürgerin Bürger wenn ihr
leistet wenn ihr euch bildet dann werdet
ihr einen Aufstieg ermöglicht haben dann
werdet ihr für die Zukunft arbeiten
können dann werden wir gemeinsam dieses
Land voranbringen dabei dann zu sagen
dass alles nur durch Obstruktion der
Opposition hinzukriegen ist mag ihre
Aufgabe sein aber am Ende wenn Wahlen
kommen werden die Bürgerin und Bürger
die Frage stellen wer hat
verfassungsrechtlich verantwortlich
gehandelt wer hat doch kritisiert wo die
Kritik notwendig ist und wer hat da
unterstützt wo es notwendig ist um die
dieses Land voranzubringen das wird die
Aufgabe sein und meine Damen und Herren
zum Schluss möchte ich an zwei drei
Dinge aus dem Urteil doch noch malinden
die Frage der Buchungsregeln sind das
eine aber sie kommen gar nicht an die
Prüfung der Buchungsregeln wenn sie sich
das Urteil genauer angucken her
Middelberg sie kommen da gar nicht ran
wenn sie vorher schon sagen dass die
jährigkeit und Jährlichkeit das ist
worum es geht und das haben sie
scheinbar bisher noch nicht erkannt und
sollten mal darüber nachdenken was das
eigentlich in Zukunft bedeutet für die
Menschen an der A wenn das
Verfassungsgericht sagt das geht nicht
wie werden wir es gemeinsam schaffen
dass wir sagen wir stehen für euch da
wir werden euch helfen egal wie lange er
braucht um die Krisen hinzukommen egal
wie lange ihr braucht um euer Haus
wieder hinzubekommen und ähnliches mehr
nach ihrer Meinung geht das alles ja gar
nicht mehr nach unserer Meinung und so
auch entsprechend dann im
nachagshaushalt werden wir helfen meine
Damen und Herren eines werden die
nächsten Wochen zeigen wer Verantwortung
zeigt und wer einfach nur
oppositionsspielchen macht herzlichen
Dank OTO frieke der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher Sprecher der FDP war das und
die letzte Rednerin in der Debatte ist
die stellvertretende
Vorsitzende des Haushaltsausschusses
nämlich Betina hagedau von der SPD
Präsidentin liebe Kollegin liebe
Kollegen lieber Otto Fricke es ist sehr
schön dass ich direkt an deine Rede
anknüpfen kann denn du hast sehr
plausibel gemacht für unsere zuhörerinen
und Zuhörer dass die Besserwisserei von
der hier der Oppositionsführer Friedrich
marz gesprochen hat
damit hat er zwar gemeint
die Regierungsbank zu meen in Wahrheit
ist es aber so dass die besser Wisser
dort sitzen und die fehlende Demut
Kollege Dobrind die Sie angesprochen
haben hier in ihrer besserwisserischen
Rede das ist schon sehr befremdlich dass
sie die nicht an Tag legen wenn sie doch
der Erfinder der pkwmaut sind wenn sie
doch derjenige waren der EU der EU-Recht
hier missachtet hat und der den
Nachfolger andreas Scheuer in die
Situation gebracht hat einen
dreistelligen Millionenbetrag zu lassen
des Steuerzahlers hier wirklich zu
veruntreuen so muss man es ja nennen und
leider ist es ja so dass sie auch keinen
einzigen Vorschlag dazu gemacht haben
wie sie eigentlich den Menschen im
arteil hier die Hand reichen wollen und
weil das so bedauerlich ist wie sie ihre
Rolle hier als große Oppositionspartei
wahrnehmen will ich Ihnen mal ein
Spiegel vorhalten wie das in meinem
Heimatland schleswiig-holstein läuft in
meinem Heimatland schleswiigholstein
davon war schon die Rede gibt es eine
schwarzgrüne Regierung mit einem CDU
Ministerpräsidenten Daniel Günther und
die werden die Haushaltsnotlage für
2023 und
2024 das möge man sich auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen erklären und wie verhält
sich dann eigentlich der
Oppositionsführer in
Schleswig-Holstein der ist nämlich
Sozialdemokrat heiß Thomas l Müller und
da hat letzte Woche eine Rede im Landtag
gehalten wo er als
Oppositionsführer an die anderen
Kollegin und Kollegen in der in der
Opposition appelliert hat in dieser
Situation die Landesregierung nicht im
Regen stehen zu lassen und er hat unter
anderem gesagt in seiner Rede mit keinem
Wort hat das Verfassungsgericht
ausgeschlossen dass wir
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen über Notkredite
finanzieren Grüße deshalb den von CD und
grün angekündigten Weg auch für das Jahr
2023 und 2024 eine erneute
hausitsnotlage festzustellen um die
jetzt notwendigen Mittel rechtssicher zu
mobilisieren und um ehrlich zu sein wäre
das auch der Weg den die Ampel in Berlin
gehen sollte alle wissen dass es die
Mittel aus dem KTF braucht für die
Wirtschaft das Verfassungsgericht hat
den Weg dahin beschrieben die
schleswig-holsteinische CDU macht vor
wie das geht das ist doch mal ein guter
und konstruktiver Beitrag aus ihren rein
und es ist vor allen Ding eine
großartige Leistung dass der
Oppositionsführer da unser Kollege von
der SPD sich eben ganz anders verhält
als Sie das hier tun ich möchte mit
Blick darauf dass wir ja noch diese
Woche den
2023er Haushalt heilen werden und die
Regierung hat ja dazu einen Vorschlag
gemacht mit dem Nachtragshaushalt den
wir am Freitag diskutieren und dann noch
im Haushaltsausschuss und die
Sachverständigen Anhörung die der
Haushaltsausschuss in der letzten
Sitzungswoche gehabt hat hat ja ganz
klar den Weg beschrieben wie wir zu
verfassungskonform Haushalten 2023 2024
kommen und viele haben hier schon gesagt
das Parlament das ist die Sternstunde
das ist unser Haushalts und Budgetrecht
und das ist richtig und darum will ich
auch an einen anderen Christdemokraten
hier erinnern der frühere Bundestag
Präsident Norbert Lammert der hat hier
in diesem Plenum nämlich sinngemäß
mehrfach geäußert in einer Demokratie
ist es nicht eine Regierung die sich ein
Parlament hält sondern es ist ein
Parlament das vom Volk direkt gewählt
ist dass eine Regierung wählt und sie
kontrolliert und übrigens wählen wir
auch unsere Verfassungsrichter und weil
das so ist und jetzt die Stunde des
Parlaments ist möchte ich als
stellvertretende
haushaltsausschussvorsitz ein Wunsch
äußern ein Wunsch auch an unsere
Regierung wir werden den 23er Haushalt
sehr Zeitner jetzt auf einen
verfassungskonformen Weg bringen aber
wir alle diskutieren im
Haushaltsausschuss seit September den
24er Haushalt und wir brauchen dringend
Planungssicherheit in diesem Land wir
müssen den Menschen den
Wohlfahrtsverbänden der Wirtschaft wir
müssen allen wieder zeigen wir sind in
der Lage diese unsich Situation wieder
zu ordnen und übrigens wir sind es auch
international in der Verantwortung denn
viele Partnerin und Partner sind auch
letztenendes davon abhängig dass wir sie
auch finanziell unterstützen und weil
das so ist darum erwarte ich dass wir
unsere Bereinigungssitzung die wir am 16
15halb Stunden geführt haben und die
Beschlüsse die wir da gefasst haben dass
die von unserer Regierung respektiert
wird und dass sie den Verfassungs kform
wie ich davorgezeichnet ist beschreitet
um diesen 2024er Haushalt mit uns mit
dem Parlament gemeinsam über die Bühne
zu bringen und zwar möglichst möglichst
ohne vorläufige Haushaltsführung weil
dann ist das Parlament nicht beteiligt
vielen
Dank Hag auch sie Sozialdemokratin
plediert dafür den haushal 2024 noch in
diesem
jahrmung über dieor
schließungsanträge der
Entschließungsantrag der ja meine Damen
und Herren und an dieser Stelle will ich
noch mal kurz zusammenfassen was wir
hier heute erlebt haben die
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
der den Bürgern verlässliche staatliche
Leistung trotz der Haushaltskrise
zugesichert hat zugleich aber auch
Sparbeschlüsse angedeutet hat der Staat
wird seine Aufgaben auch weiterhin
gerecht werden hat Bundeskanzler Scholz
gesagt hat noch mal gerechtfertigt dass
die Schuldenbremse auch in diesem Jahr
ausgesetzt werden muss und hat für meine
Erinnerung doch eher gesagt dass man
sich Zeit lassen muss um jetzt zu
überlegen wie man den Haushalt 24
verfassungskonform bekommt die
Sozialdemokraten in dieser Debatte haben
den Weg klar vorgezeigt sie sagen wir
wollen in diesem Jahr noch abschließen
das bedeutet die Schuldenbremse auch auf
das Jahr 2024 auszuweiten dagegen wird
sich zunächst noch die FDP und auch die
Union hat hier gesagt da würde sie nicht
mitmachen aber für diesen Schritt sind
auch gar nicht gebraucht sondern für den
Schritt den die grüne Fraktionschefin
dröge andeutete dass eben die
Schuldenbremse verändert werden muss
Investitionen müssen zugänglich gemacht
werden dafür bräuchte die
Bundesregierung allerdings die
Zustimmung der CDU CSU hier im Hohen
Hause denn es wäre dann eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit notwendig um das
Grundgesetz zu verändern und noch ein
Wort zum Oppositionschef Friedrich März
hat hier wirklich in einer venten Rede
den Bundeskanzler quasi zerlegt sie sind
ein klemtner der Macht hat er ihm
vorgeworfen ihnen fehlt J jliche
Vorstellung wie sich das Land
fortentwickeln soll verglichen mit
brandchmidtchröder muss man spätestens
nach der heutigen Regierungserklärung
feststellen sie können es nicht und das
waren Töne die ein nicht hoffnungsvoll
stimmen können in der Frage ob in dieser
Krise Koalition und Opposition
zusammengehen können wenn man es
zusammenfasst muss man sagen die Ampel
muss ich vor allen Dingen für den
Haushalt 2024 zusammenraufen ob das noch
in diesem Jahr klappt ob die
Schuldenbremse ein neu mal ausgesetzt
wird für das Jahr 2024 oder ob das was
der bundeskanz auch schon angedeutet hat
dass es harte Sparbeschlüsse geben muss
ob das umgesetzt wird was auch die FDP
will das bleibt jetzt abzuwarten in den
Gesprächen der nächsten Tage und Wochen
aber wir haben ja bekanntlich schon bald
Weihnachten also ob das dieses Jahr noch
klappt wir werden es sehen ein
ereignisreicher Vormittag hier im
Deutschen Bundestag wir melden uns hier
aus dem Bundestag wieder morgen am
Mittwoch um 13 Uhr mit der Befragung der
bundesreg und das soll von mir gewesen
sein ich gebe zurück zu Claudia Davis
nach Bonn